preserving endangered species is no easy
task and sometimes it takes a bit of
creativity to get the job done come take
a closer look at wildlife and their most
dedicated Guardians with these five
stories this fuzzy little creature is a
Kaka and these guys live here off the
west coast of Australia on Rottnest
Island quokkas are not only cute they
are camera-ready
and they're taking the internet by storm
so let's start at the beginning what is
a Kaka a Kaka is a small wallaby it
comes from the same family as a kangaroo
and physically they've got thick brown
fur they've got long tails and they hop
around corkers thrive on Rottnest Island
because they don't have any predators
over here so there's no foxes we have
the largest viable population of about
10,000 oh sorry and you are
my name is Cassie Anna GREs and I'm a
conservation officer on Rottnest Island
in my role I'm responsible for managing
conservation programs and there's one
online trend that has really helped
these animals a cooker selfie but make
sure you're getting it right how to take
a caucus selfie step one a camera step
two a corker but don't touch the caucus
ah nope or feed them it's 150 dollar
fine these guys don't need the food they
naturally graze their way through the
islands vegetation and I also really
love the savings that we plan as part of
our revegetation projects that we have
implemented by our environment
technicians sorry about that guys
thanks for all your hard work and what
makes these guys so great for taking
selfies around the settlement area the
Crockers are a lot friendlier they've
become used to people so their natural
behavior has changed but out in the
reserve where they're actually still
exhibiting their natural behavior there
will be a lot more wary of people we
have to know are they actually smiling
in photos yeah they're not actually
smiling in the photo is it's just the
natural shape of their mouth which comes
up at the side which makes them look
like they're smiling
the popularity of
the clock selfie has given us the
opportunity to be able to raise
awareness about the Crockers
particularly on the mainland that are
under threat so we use that as a
platform to educate the public and also
educate them about appropriate
interaction with wildlife so finally a
good cause for selfies
[Music]
this is aya and sagu two adorable
clouded leopard cubs don't be fooled by
the youthful spirit clouded leopards are
some of the most shy mysterious and
elusive cats besides their shy nature
they have a steadily declining
population making it even harder to spot
them in the wild
as far as big cats go clouded leopards
are the smallest these two little girls
will top out at around 3 feet when fully
grown native throughout Asia they live
in diverse habitats from the rain
forests of Indonesia to the foothills of
the Himalayas they pack a powerful bite
- as they have the largest canine teeth
relative to body size of any wild cat
they have short powerful legs and ankles
that convert eight backwards making them
elite climbers beyond a quickly
shrinking habitat perching remains a
huge problem as their skin claws teeth
burns and meat are all sold on the black
market this is the clouded leopard
we look at every subject that we want to
fill and then we say well what is the
best way to get into their world
it's an amazing moment when you realize
that you're actually seeing some stuff
for the first time my name's John downer
and these are my incredible between of
spy creatures well I suppose it all
started when I started baking wildlife
films and I wanted to have that kind of
intimate perspective to get into the
animal world and actually know what it's
like to be an animal over the years use
technology to get more and more inside
the animal world and those things have
progressed we would move from just using
remote cameras disguises rocks to where
we are today which is having you know
these incredible spy creatures which are
able to do filming cameras in their eyes
really look like the animals and the
animals we interact with them the whole
idea of you know using the robots that
came about when we made a film about
penguins for the first time we thought
well what if we made a penguin can of
living moving camera they look like a
penguin that was able to go into the
colony and start to count on these
incredible shots you can't explain it
because it's it's a dream come true I
think part of the the whole technique is
is to try and get inside the animals
minds you know understanding animal
behavior is key to it already
[Music]
we lost one spy pup to a wharf by
tortoise is it possible by an elephant
and I think it's something about the
fact that they look living makes them
think before they actually do anything
and if it's not a threat then they kind
of requite like it
[Music]
the challenges are they are innumerable
because everything is a challenge from
the beginning to the point you get the
film the animals once you get there and
once you've actually with them they tend
to be the least of all the problems they
usually do deliver because they do
amazing things and if you've got the
technology to be a have to film close to
them and in their world you know you
what you know you're going to get
something remarkable
[Music]
[Music]
alimony in Kenya no wildlife
conservation areas they are quiet
[Music]
this all changes when the phone rings
topic açaí the team can be contacted at
all times
we are the first mobile security patrol
virtual team in this part of Kenya
typically an animal is trapped in
approach is near but it can be anything
a lion which needs to be translocated or
a sick zebra but usually the Spanish
orchids include gloves first-aid kit
medical supplies blindfold rope and
guarding life the team consists of a
driver one admit and two Rangers once
you have assembled everything we are
ready to go and save the animals
the rolls are not usually failed most of
the time we play through the bush we are
going to see
enriched and more you have to keep them
and more 7 oz himself has become
debilitated because of the snails
naughty - we only have a few minutes
ones and must been tranquilized and it
can be very traumatic
complete back in the compound we are
bigger team just have one more keeper
take care of the orphans our lab
technician takes care of the blood walk
a Kohana manages our online presence
this job is important because as is a
lot of conflict to human beings and
wildlife
therefore in Division who save wildlife
from becoming extinct is very crucial I
love so much to save lives and see
animals our and that's our calling
that's why I do the job growing up in
Montana I feel like I had kind of a
special opportunity just to be outside a
lot that's kind of where a love of
wildlife started for me that dies out
and a lot of kids and for me it just
continued my name is Wesley Larson I'm a
master's student working in wildlife
conservation and then uh some circles
I'm known as Triscuit when I first
started deciding that I should get into
a wildlife field I found dr. Tom Smith
at BYU I started by working with polar
bears on Alaska's North Slope and then
that kind of transition into some black
bear work down here in Utah in Bryce
Canyon Bryce Canyon like other national
parks that do have bears they've had a
kind of a history with with visitor
conflict and with bears that maybe are
getting into campsite so what we're
doing is we're tracking the bears to
learn what habitats they're using just
to see what the park could do better to
make it easier for visitors to avoid
bears
what we're doing is we're fitting black
bears with GPS collars and then I'll go
into the den with the bear to inject it
with some drugs the bear then falls
asleep I can pull it out and you know
just give it a full checkup
it's probably the most scary thing we do
just because bears wake up sometimes
they're really unhappy to see us stay
stay stay
[Music]
hey stay Jenna I have had to crawl up
trees after bears it's it's an
interesting job for sure people do have
this knee-jerk reaction to see an animal
that's sedated or an animal that's
wearing a collar and think that you know
it might be being hurt and the thing
that they don't realize is that we
really care about these animals probably
more than just about anyone getting out
into the wilderness and having these
kind of experiences this helps you
understand that we depend on wildlife
and wildlife depends on us and that's
really what conservation is all about
giving the space and the respect to
these animals that they deserve and
really learning as much about them as we
can
you
[Music]